If a quadratic equation is in this form, we can simply divide both sides by a,
and then take the square root of both sides to find x. If we divide both sides
by a, we'll get x squared is equal to c divided by a. And now we take the
square root of both sides. When we take the square root of both sides, we need
to add a plus or minus symbol in front of the side that doesn't have a
variable. And here's why we include this plus or minus sign. Think about if I
had x squared equals 1. I know there are really two values that make this true.
Positive 1 squared would equal 1, and negative 1 squared would also equal 1.
This means when we solve and take the square root of both sides. We need to add
the plus or minus symbol to account for both the positive and the negative
answer. The square root of x squared is x and the square root of 1 is 1. So
really x could be positive 1 like we thought or x could equal negative 1. So
you see if you can use the square root method. Try solving this equation by
following these steps.